[Music]  Google how you doing man  haven't seen you around yo fart it's  time for the cool you guys to come in  this job you know as a yeah you do  nobody actually loves you you're just  default you know yeah you know people  mostly use me for is more than porn it's  it's not just not that not that that's  it's like educational because I got  SafeSearch watch this  yeah you don't even know what that is  yeah you both bleed out could be  anything you are distracting me from am  i upgrade so if you could take some of  these and then go away yeah whatever you  upgrade complete  is inside the primary objective  [Music]  you just need to ask yourself one  question or I feel lucky  do ya  [Music]